autism is something that many people
know about for example some people think
that autistic people are fair-skinned
males that speak in monotone and
constantly go on and on about the same
topic some people think that autistic
people do not know right from wrong
avoid attention and usually say the
wrong thing at the wrong time some
people think that autistic people are
socially awkward and lack humor and
empathy now if you agree with what I
just said I'm sorry to tell you but you
do not have the right impression of
autism how do I know because I have
autism I do have my own obsessions with
things like electronics and public
transit but that does not define me
each of us are different and unique in
our own way however there is not a lot
of information out there on what an
autistic life actually looks like so
people often resort to stereotypes and
we see these often in the media some of
the more common stereotypes in the media
include being socially awkward lacking
empathy and even being a super genius
and the lack of knowledge on autism
doesn't stop there either did you know
some people are trying to find a cure
for autism that's because they see it as
a negative thing as a disease many
people are challenging the idea and to
us we think autism is not a disease it's
just another way of thinking and looking
at the world our brains function
differently from most people's brains
think of it like comparing an Xbox and a
Playstation they're both highly capable
consoles with different programming but
if you put your xbox game in a
Playstation it won't work because the
PlayStation communicates differently
when I look in the mirror I see someone
who thinks differently oh and I also see
nice hair but the question is am I
really diseas'd if I just think
differently
the main problem was living autistic in
today's society is that the world just
doesn't built for us there are so many
ways that we can get overwhelmed for
example the thing that makes me
overwhelmed all the time is loud noises
which means I never crank up my music
really loud and I usually am NOT a fan
of large parties but other people on the
spectrum might get overwhelmed with
things like bright lights or strong
smells or gooey textures that all of the
potential to create anxiety think about
all the social gatherings you've been to
in the past was there loud music playing
where they're really bright lights where
there are lots of different food smells
going on at the same time where there
are lots of conversations happening all
at once those things may not have
bothered you guys but for someone with
autism they can be quite overwhelming so
in those situations we do something
called stimming which is like a
repetitive motion or a noise or some
other random fidgeting that may or may
not seem normal
some people will flap their arms or make
a noise or spin yeah that's basically
our way of zoning out
it can often feel necessary for us to
stim however it's often frowned upon and
we're forced to hide it when we're
forced to hide our autistic traits like
this it's called masking some people
mask better than others I mask so well
sometimes that people don't even know
I'm autistic until I give them the big
reveal but at the end of the day it gets
really stressful
even something like doing my homework at
night becomes very tiring some people
think that because of our ability to
mask that this is the cure to autism
however all it really does is makes us
ashamed of showing our true selves
another common stereotype that is often
associated with autism is that autistic
people lack empathy and again this is
not true I actually have lots of empathy
I'm just not really good at showing it
whenever a friend is trying to tell me
some of the struggles that they're going
through I often don't know how to
express my reply and that is why I don't
show as much empathy as mine on autistic
friends do emotional expression however
much or however little is difficult for
me and that is because I am bursting
inside with every single motion one
feels at all times though of course I
cannot express it that way otherwise
let's say happiness for example would
come out as a huge burst of gleeful
wheezing hand flapping and loud vocal
woo-hoos whereas you may just smile
whether it be receiving an awesome
birthday gift or listening to a tragic
story on the news I cannot really
express my reply without bursting so
once again I have to mask it in order to
appear normal my inner feelings are
unlimited but my mind only lets me
express extremes or nothing so my I'm
not - I'm not great with my emotions and
I communicate differently and because of
that I was diagnosed with autism
spectrum disorder this diagnosis helps
me and my friends and family to know how
my mind works and in the world
approximately 1% of the population is
diagnosed with autism spectrum disorder
and this number is growing however we
are still a big minority and there are
still lots of people that do not see us
as equals to other people this is my
family and in my family there is one
other person who is also autistic my
mother yes adult woman can also be
autistic my dad and my brother are both
non-autistic sometimes it can be a bit
difficult for us to communicate with
each other however sometimes I'll say
something like Oh Toronto's Union
Station right thinking that I can help
them to remember certain aspects of it
when they get confused I often have to
elaborate myself on that and we often
have to say things in a number of
different ways that everyone understands
however despite all that we all love
each other and respect
teach others equals in his book narrow
tribes author Steve Silberman states
that autism and other mental conditions
should be seen as naturally human
naturally part of a human spectrum and
not as defects and this is something
that I agree to completely if autism was
seen as part of a natural human spectrum
then the world could be a design to work
better for autistic people I am not
ashamed of my autism and I may not think
like you or act like you but I'm still
human and I am NOT diseased thank you
[Applause]